this is what happens when I sit down
yeah that's normal in mid-may the male
romper craze hit social media after a
Kickstarter campaign for the romp him
went viral we reached out to the wrong
team team to see if we could get samples
but because the Kickstarter was a wildly
successful there weren't any rock cabs
available so we did what we had to do
ordered mail rompers from China off eBay
and guess what they just came in the
mail I've totally seen the romp em I've
seen it on social media it kind of blew
up about a month ago I heard a little
bit about ROM PIMs I am my understanding
that's a specific brand a romper is like
a adult version of a onesie construction
workers are wearing like Male rompers
I'm gonna wear the romper tomorrow I'm
expecting the moment I step out of my
apartment I'm gonna be very self
conscious about it okay so here's my
romper I'm happy to see that it's black
because I wear a lot of black ah okay
yep just as I suspected there is no butt
flap so you will have to strip down
naked to go to the bathroom my first
impression is like Steve Irwin may rest
in peace oh hold on these pockets are
[ __ ] fake I hope this looks good on
my butt I'm excited for this tomorrow I
think it's gonna be really good I think
okay I just got into the shower and
today is romper day I'm ready to put it
on hope it fits bone let's check it out
these shorts are pretty tight okay I
forget about it
Chandler what do you think - come
further down my legs than their romper
that it's it's comfy that's pretty good
actually
fYI this is not romper weather that I
feel gross at the humanistic
but I look cute I look like I'm about to
go on safari and I'm wet
but I'm CUBAN how good do we look I'm
feeling good looking gorgeous I think he
looks good too okay so here's the deal
I've had two coffees this morning and it
is time for me to use the bathroom
so I have to fully get unclothed before
I can go to the bathroom because there's
a blood flap
I am completely naked at my job right
now this is weird okay it was successful
there's a lot of maneuvering you have to
make sure that you don't think drop your
romper on the ground it's also cold but
you know what we did it we made it there
I just saw Matt and look how freaking
good he looks what do you think of it
you look like a summertime Ghostbuster
what do you think of my outfit I think
you look like Steve Irwin Crocodile
Hunter ok I'm in the bathroom at the bar
and this is just getting so hot and also
just like constricting every time I lift
up my shoulders my way up no hang I'm
ready to be done with it
romper day is officially over I just
have to say it was super fun I didn't
love wearing a romper best part of
worrying that romper was just waking up
in the morning and knowing exactly what
its gonna wear rompers are also super
comfortable like really really
comfortable rappers are not for me so
I'm not gonna wear the rubber if you
won't wear rubber you should wear it I
totally get out rock one again maybe one
a little bit like longer shorts I think
all people should wear whatever the [ __ ]
they want just because someone says this
is something that men wear or women wear
it doesn't mean that you can't have your
own spin on it or do something that you
want to do my one piece of advice is
just like make sure the floor is not wet
below the toilet before you wear a
rubber
[Music]